a new poll on the reliability of
journalists comes from pew which makes
sense because it stinks for the press
less than half of Americans have a great
deal of confidence in them I wonder why
the beginning of the end of the Trump
presidency he's got to know his future
looks like it's behind bars it's clear
that mother is now connecting the dots
between a massive obstruction intended
to hide the truth and it's just cloud
about collusion with Russia will hang
over him no matter where he stands
president sees the walls closing in and
is lashing out the presidency is
effectively a Russian op that's a
montage so Americans rank the press
behind lawyers and above elected
officials that's like saying you're
worse than vermin but not as bad as lice
sorry Emily but the numbers would have
been worse were it not for Fox News the
reason we're awesome which is why the
other guys hate us so much
it seems like other cable networks exist
just to watch Fox Fox News Fox News Fox
News this is what Fox is about Fox News
out of Fox News figures on Fox News Fox
News watching Fox Fox News my god what
if we stopped working CNN would have to
actually cover news but then who could
they blame everything on right Chris
everyone around him has a mask on he
does it because he wants to keep up the
Fox farce this BS that kovat 19 is
overrated
I guess the anti elitist over there are
okay with 10,000 more dead oh what a
child so this guy has the gall to blame
us for future death what about death
that already happened ie the actual
thousands in rest homes he failed to ask
his bro about because he had other
things on his mind do you think that you
are an attractive person now because
you're single and ready to mingle do you
really think you are some desirable
single person and that this is not just
people's pain coming out of them
I think beauties in the ayah
beholder and 5200 people died in rest
homes
anyway the polls suggest the media
doesn't act on behalf of the public
probably because they hate the public
the press is over educated cloistered
far removed from people who actually
make things their idea of slumming it is
non organic quinoa I wonder if the media
became truly diverse especially in
perspective would they have gotten so
much wrong with a mr. Trump's victory or
seeing through the collusion and
obstruction hoax the impeachment
travesty would they have seen the
coronavirus coming instead of drooling
over atom ships lies would they have
seen Michael Flynn for what he was a
hero getting screwed the fact is we know
the media's broken and the only entity
not reporting it is the media we need a
12-step program for the press the first
one would be to buy them a mirror Emily
what's your take on the poll Emily oh
sorry I'm sorry I didn't hear that
someone was in my ear um what was the
question
nothing I was just sick gonna say hi
they told me to be fast but apparently
they screwed it all up what are your
thoughts okay look I just I think that
um I think everyone underestimates the
power of an autonomy of every individual
to make their own decision and that's
why I'm so proud and honored to work
here because we convey everything so
that the viewer can make their own
decision a couple decades ago I used to
commute to work on a ferry and every day
I read the physical paper of that
metropolis as main paper and it was so
one-sided it disgusted me I stopped
reading it and I've sort of had a
suspicion about them ever since that it
grew but it was I who made that decision
the rest of the media isn't giving their
viewers or their listeners a choice yeah
you know Jesse one thing I like about
you is your ability for self reflection
why is that missing in other parts of
the media I don't know if I knew I'd
tell you Greg but I just I don't have
that type of ability I did Emily just
say she like reads a periodical on a
ferry to a metropolis yes
okay also Greg before I say something
serious like what would ever happen if
you met Cuomo at a bar or something like
that how do you think that would go
between you guys I don't know I have a
feeling we don't go to the same bars
yeah yeah maybe but if you did I just
had a feeling it might not go so well
for you the only serious point I have
for this is this this the same people
that brought us Russia collusion are now
telling us Obama gate is a conspiracy
right the media they don't care they get
it all wrong everything they say is
usually it's the opposite like if they
say that the Obama spy gate thing was
done by the books you know it was dirty
as sin yeah that's all I have to say
Dana I'm a theory that division is the
hamburger helper of CNN they take a
story they figure out how to divide and
that makes the story bigger it's their
hamburger helper I loved a hamburger
helper indeed you know it's pretty
interesting the 48% of people actually
have a great deal or a fair amount of
trust in the media so I mean maybe that
is something to look at in terms of the
polarization that we have I'm not
exactly sure but I do think it is quite
rich that somebody who was recovering
from coronavirus went on Ferris
Bueller's Day Off and then pretended
that he didn't and then staged his
re-emergence from his basement after he
recovered from coronavirus yeah that's a
classic it will live forever one last
word - you agree with me if you must I
have - well how can I argue with you
Gregory
I was taken by what you said because you
said as Dana just pointed out it's like
half of the American people do have some
or a high degree of confidence in the
media but fewer have confidence in our
politicians and I think that the polls
show even on the coronavirus again about
50% of Americans trust the media but
only like 35% trust the president so you
know I mean you could play it anything
either way you wish we don't have
confidence in all
because I want Emily to be able to read
her journal on her ferry and know that
it's the truth there you go all right